[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
racontez moi quand tu étais au pays de
ge energy
parmi tous me souvenir il en est un que
veut n'oublierai jamais de celui de
l'est tél
[Musique]
enfin petit moment de repos base aurait
bien mérité
nous avons à nous laisser tranquille je
réussis un beau bateau dont le donnerait
à pérenniser vous demande de mettre sur
orbite à tuer là je suis sous six mois
on veut compris toi tu as encore des
ennuis
ils sont là s'ils ne poursuivent qui
nous fut c'est bien fait pour toi tu
n'avais pas rater c'est toi en tutu ce
cash mois ici il arrive à ce point
derrière moi but ici ici ici ici ici
comment trouver mon bateau mais petit
frère ne parlent pas tous à la fois et
laissez-moi traduire or vous faire
fédérer ni stéphane qui si elle est bien
mauvais élève vous ne pouvez pas
l'attraper
ici elle est où la rose au sommet d'une
colonne et pour la prendre il faut
monter sur une selle vous avez raison
mais petit frère à les buts a fait une
telle équipe est bien vite ternissent
ils feront pas mieux étant propice sans
perdre une minute
voyons que qobuz de moi tu parlais de ma
petit howie vendu tôt quand c'est propre
à une reviennent dit pas derrière voilà
les stèles non non non la pause et par
ici c'est la batterie pour la mettre ici
ici ici et ici
mettez là debout on tournerait plus
facilement y fit que le cube de deux
bourdes et vous continuez vous allez
vous comptez les vans bon on a des
progrès à présent avant kiki smith
je vais les éloigner dit si on prend la
direction des opérations
virez moi à mon commandement ma question
est on s'arrête ici
allons bon nankin va vite rattraper cela
irait on était tous les deux avant vous
avez trouvé la mort hier après dans je
vais vous dire où et d'égréner une série
d'interdits béni et là haut pour la pape
et il faut monter les pelles que le plus
courageux ont bousculé pas y en aura
pour tout le monde
cela te tiens les ailes toit se situe
monde d'accord qui fit voler les 41 au
sommet de la colonne mais n'y arrivent
jamais comme un manque de barras et 6 me
dit vous allez monter en avion ça vous
plaît sans lever les scènes au dessus de
votre tête
ceux ci avancent d'un pas tu es bien
ceux-là recule d'un pas cet enfant a
tenté un mouvement d'ensemble a baissé
les bras
la voilà lancée tout c'est réussi qui
ici l'avion décolle dans le cinq minutes
data vos ceintures de sécurité comme ça
aux attentes et un émoi au fus
il me cherchais toujours notons qu'un
pas c'est de négoce de croix en avion et
il adore le décollage et après après est
une autre histoire
[Applaudissements]